nearly half the population of ethiopia's
tigrai region is going hungry that's the
warning from the world food programme
degran leaders are accused of refusing
talks with the federal government so is
peace a condition to ending the
humanitarian crisis this is inside story
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm laura kyle it's been called the
worst disaster on earth and now the
situation in ethiopia's tegra region is
expected to worsen the un says the
nearly two-year conflict has left almost
half the population in severe need of
food aid that's despite a unilateral
ceasefire in march which allowed the
delivery of aid to resume humanitarian
groups say they are still struggling to
reach millions of people in need because
of fuel shortages as a result
malnutrition rates have skyrocketed the
un has called for urgent action to avert
further disaster in the war-torn region
where funding is running out fast
conflict extremist groups coupled with
the driest season that we have seen
in decades four or five rainy seasons
have just disappeared and in the past
four decades the driest we've ever seen
it in a long long time people
are losing hope but the world food
program if we get the support and the
money we need
we can save lives and we can bring hope
well meanwhile the head of the world
health organization has described the
humanitarian crisis in tigrai as the
worst in the world tedros adam
gabrielesis who is from the region
implied that the international
community's silence may be racially
motivated
in terms of humanitarian crisis
i can tell you that
the humanitarian crisis integra is more
than ukraine
without any exaggeration
and i said it many months ago
maybe the reason is the color of the
skin of the people integra
i haven't heard in the last five few
months several months now even a head of
state talking about that condition
anywhere
in the developed world especially
why
i think we know
well ethiopia's government reacted to
these comments calling them unethical
and one-sided the comment is uh one
among many unethical ones that has been
made by the who director general and is
not surprising
using the race card and one's
multilateral position to garner the
sympathy of the global north for
personal partisan politics is quite
unbecoming of such a high profile
position
we have no doubt that the united nations
will review the continued breach of the
un's uh oath of office by the who
director general wherein the oath of
office itself
clearly requires you and staff to act
with impartiality and independence
well let's take a closer look at the
latest wfp report tigray is in northern
ethiopia and home to around five and a
half million people the un says 90
percent of the population are food
insecure and nearly half severely in
need of food it says half of all
pregnant or breastfeeding women are
malnourished 33 percent of children
under five also fall into this category
and it's not just tigray neighboring
afar and amhara regions are also
affected an estimated 13 million people
need food assistance an increase of 44
since january
well let's bring in our guests now and
in ankara we have sued hassan to cry an
activist in cambridge william davidson
senior ethiopia analyst for
international crisis group and in
canterbury is bizune getachu yemeneux
ethiopia researcher and lecturer at the
university of kent a very warm welcome
to all of you
let's start by saying and pointing out
that tigre is a very difficult region to
access it's been mostly closed to
journalists since the start of the
conflict around nearly two years ago
sued what communication do you have with
people in the region and what can you
tell us about the situation there
well the situation is extremely dire
and we know the communication service is
completely out of service and it's
deliberately deliberately done by the
government of ethiopia because at the
early stage we we saw that
from media outlets one truth and
give
extremely uh
clear image what is happening in the
drive the
genocide committed integra but currently
we don't have to be honest a clear
communication with our family uh we
don't have what is happening um except
the fact that many people are dying
because of the
draconian siege
implemented by the government of egypt
so basically what we know so far is that
people are dying and the international
community is ignoring what's happening
in the drive as the doctor figure says
that
this
is clear that
many people doesn't want to discuss but
it is
uh clearly ignored but not the fact that
cigra is ignored at this point but at
early
2010s uh
it was also ignored in yemen
and
of course in somalia as well
i do want to get back to uh ted ross's
comments
just a little later in the discussion
for the moment let's just stick with the
situation and get a clear picture for
our viewers as much as we can as to
what's happening in the region william
the ethiopian government declared a
unilateral but humanitarian ceasefire in
march so why is enough aid still not
getting through
i think that's primarily um for two
reasons um one is that there has been
very heavy restrictions
on
normal trading relations so access to
the region and the normal humanitarian
operations and also these
critically these public services um
including banking so they've been
restricted during this conflict
and although there has been some
improvement this year um including since
that
truce in in march um because um there is
only a sort of limited opening of this
blockade it hasn't been able to meet the
needs in scientific ways so primarily
we've seen
a significant increase in food
aid
but through quite indirect route
and also that has not been accompanied
by sufficient fuel to be able to deliver
that increased food aid around the
region and then we still have the
federal government blocking public
services the region and this comes on
top of a devastating conflict and a
conflict where there was
um
systematic destruction of agricultural
equipment um seeds fertilizers being
stolen also destruction to other vital
infrastructure and services including
health and education
and then we have the banking outage as
well so you can imagine this all adds up
to a very dire situation and just
because there's been some improvement
over the last few months it means you
cannot alleviate all these problems that
have accumulated over two years for
those multiple reasons
so how have people been surviving
they've essentially been people are
calling it been under siege
how have they coped with this situation
during this conflict how have they
managed to survive so far to be honest i
cannot give you a clear image on this
record because we don't know what is the
complete picture in the ground because
we have no communication to
see what's happening in the drive but
the information we gathered so far is
that it is very dire and
hundreds uh
of people in fact thousands of people
are dying each day
the biggest
hospital integra is completely closed
because they cannot give any service
because there is no medicine there is no
equipment there is nothing
as uh william actually clearly stated
that even people who actually have
shaving in their account they cannot
access their account to survive
this is a deliberate action by the
government so that they can implement a
genocide
for the fact that
they don't need to fire any bullet to
accomplish their actions so as i said
earlier this is
uh a completely uh
we are in a very completely dangerous
phase uh at this moment
and honestly speaking
we don't know what is clearly happening
in terms
so far we know that thousands of people
especially
children in the women are dying each day
okay bizuna let's bring you in here
because sue just used a very strong the
strongest term genocide he said the
ethiopian government is committing
genocide in the tiguai region first of
all do you do you agree with that
it is difficult to to make such such
conclusion because an independent body
which is impartial should investigate
this
incident throughout from the very
beginning up to
the moment by going to the field and
investigating who did what because
atrocities have been committed by both
sides and different reporters including
international organizations and the
european human rights commission also
mentioned that both parties or all the
parties to the conflict have committed
as atrocities so
you know
naming or
mentioning or stating the extent of
the crime is difficult unless it is
investigated by an independent body
regarding all the issues going on there
then let's get back to the siege
situation why are basic services still
cut off why is not enough fuel reaching
the region is it because as soon says it
allows the pressure to be kept on the
tplf without firing a single bullet in
this regard the federal government
repeatedly mentioned
that it is working it is best in order
to deliver humanitarian services to the
region including
fuel and all the essentials are needed
all the essentials needed obviously for
a region of more than six million
population
you know
trucks of food might not be sufficient
and this long
the region have been uh
not accessing any service from the
neighboring region or any other country
so
it is difficult to say that it is
sufficient obviously it is not
sufficient but the federal government
mentioned that that the region is trying
to use the opportunity in order to you
know transfer or get access to foreign
and local currencies and build up the
the military capacity required to launch
another offense against the federal
government so
the problem is both sides are accusing
each other uh rather than you know
working towards uh common purpose
especially saving the lives of millions
of uh people integra especially women
and children who
are victim of this war so the issue is
not only integra in neighboring regions
of afar amhara as well and other parts
of the country including rome where
there are some issues going on because
of the conflict between the federal
government and the insurgencies
so this broad issue should be considered
and
it should be resolved in negotiations so
that people
can get access and lives can be saved
okay william do you
see the ethiopian government
prioritizing the humanitarian situation
there or is it prioritizing
ending the tplf fighting the threat that
it poses yeah i think as you can see
from forbiddenie's answer there um there
are of course your massive political
considerations here um this your
terrible humanitarian situation inside
tigray and elsewhere is largely the
product of
of conflict and everything that comes
with it and that conflict's a result of
political disagreement now without
passing judgment um i think you suffice
to say part of the federal strategy here
has been to try and
subjugate the tplf tigre's leadership by
weakening tigre overall and that has
involved
collective punishment of the tigrayan
people at times
and it certainly does seem that these
continued restrictions on for example
banking services
not allowing the restoration of
telecommunications even and this is a
continuation of the political military
strategy that the federal government has
pursued essentially throughout this war
um now other you know some
justifications for that of course people
make arguments that
because the tigray region the tplf is an
open rebellion the federal government
has no obligation um to deliver these
federal services but the result
um is harm collective suffering for the
tigran people and the federal government
does have an obligation to provide
humanitarian services allow humanitarian
services and even into conflict of
affected areas so i think there's no
doubt here really
that um the political military
considerations are being prioritized by
the federal government also by other
actors including the tiguay leadership
um at the the expense of civilian
suffering yeah that's a good point sued
why won't the tough leadership come to
the negotiating table actually the
secretary government is open for
negotiation the the reason why we the
military uh tda
is returned from outskirts of the
capital is to give peace a chance but
there was expectation that from our side
that there will be unfortunately
monetary corridor and there will be open
uh
for uh presumption of basic services
this didn't happen the other thing
for a negotiation to start i think the
basic thing we have to attain is that
every uh
forces they should have to
maintain that the status quanta which
means that all the forces from uh
our land or federalists have to
return to their uh
position before november 3.
so
i think negotiation only can work that
if
a trust is viewed between two uh uh
parts and there is nothing that we can
observe from the african government that
is
that is going to be leveled as a
trustworthy so still the position of the
government is peace should have to be
prioritized but
uh i don't think the indian government
is willing to leadership by any uh
standard from what we observe
always
uh they are not open the reason why the
government of ethiopia were stating that
the reason was that
the government of tedra
is
unwilling to give a security for the
technicians to fix the problem
but
even now when the government of
secretary provides a letter that
guarantees the technicians will be
secure
with the
diplomats went to mapala the goalpost is
changed now the government of italy has
now stated that the basic service
only will be open if uh negotiated
ceasefire
is shined okay so every time that
you just jump in there because do you
agree with that do you agree that the
ethiopian government is changing the
goal posts and asking more and more and
more of the tegrans to come to the
negotiation table i think the federal
government already announced especially
last week that
the government wants to start the peace
talk as quickly as possible and it made
a call for the regional government of
tigre
to start the peace corps without without
any precondition but
as as already mentioned the tiguay
government mentioned that they want the
waste degree to
reincorporate it and come under the
administration of degray region and the
services should be uh
started before negotiation and i i
assume that the federal government want
to make the west great case part of the
negotiation than making the precondition
of negotiation so in this case it is
difficult that the country looks like in
a deadlock where the tigra is not uh
giving up the claim over
over the land not to give up but
making it as a precondition for for the
negotiation a western integra
is a major sticking point isn't it but
the point that sued just made then was
that there needs to be some trust uh
installed in the process and and even
ted ross the who director general said
that the ball is in the ethiopian
government's hands yeah the building's
trust is very important for for
negotiation to be successful but the
problem is these two parties have been
in devastating conflict and i don't
think trust can happen overnight unless
both parties try to compromise and at
least minimize their demands to start
dialogue to the minimum and prioritize
the people rather than
only considering the power our conflict
as well
william let's look at the international
attention or lack of it on this conflict
and and that statement that we heard
earlier from the who direct general ted
ross saying that or suggesting that
racism was behind the lack of attention
when you consider how much focus is on
ukraine compared to t grey do you think
that's a fair comment i think i'm not
going to you know respond directly to
that i think you should reach out to
the who and ted ross for explanation
there um i think we're dealing with a
very complex
um political humanitarian military
situation um inside ethiopia and
antigrain i think there's a number of
factors at play
um i think with the best will in the
world um which we don't have you know
the external actors would struggle to
influence positively some of the
positions of the ethiopian protagonists
here
because this is an ethiopian civil war
and there are very deeply
felt reasons for it um you know maybe
just to say i think um understandably
um ted ross is pointing to what he
perceives as a double standard in terms
of the level of media attention
government attention um to the
respective crises and and i think those
are the sorts of inconsistencies double
standards um we can unfortunately
identify
all over the place if just to look more
broadly then if there is the access
available to tigray will there be enough
international aid to
help those people in the region to get
out of this state of hunger
well it's a little bit difficult for me
to answer that sort of logistics
question i think you know the aid supply
has been scaled up reasonably
impressively um as the access has become
more available of course you know as
we've been discussing you know a massive
boost to the tigran economy here and
therefore you know that would really um
sustainably alleviate the humanitarian
situation that would be the reconnection
of tikrai to the national economy both
in terms of transport and trade
as well as those services and normal
banking operation
power and telecommunications all these
things
um would be a massive shot in the arm
for the situation inside tigre um and
and presumably yes you know the the
there is
there would be the ability to scale up
the operation
um further um as as access improves
bizuna would would you feel
what do you feel about the extent of the
international attention of the
international involvement in uh the
negotiating process do you feel that if
there was more that would have been
further down the road already now or as
william says is this a highly
complicated inter-ethiopian
situation yeah the the dynamics is
changing it is very dynamic and complex
situation the country is in and has been
through since uh especially november
2020
international praiser might play certain
roles but that pressure should be
balanced
the government of ethiopia
continuously complained that the
pressure has been on the government on
the federal government only and the tpla
for the
region has faced an operation from from
international community in this case for
example they mentioned that
we have we are ready to start a
negotiation without precondition but the
tplf is listing list of preconditions to
be fulfilled and the international
community is not putting any pressure
and imbalance in terms of reporting even
the war so in this case
this problem should be
entirely solved by by ethiopian
internally but this does not mean that
international community has nothing to
to contribute
they can play in in terms of
facilitating the negotiation and putting
pressure on both sides and facilitating
even humanitarian access uh as much as
possible by closely working with with
both governments and the african union
is in this case
has been playing some role but that
should be you know
more facilitated and it sometimes lose
momentum now the tension is rising
between the two groups and
each party are accusing each other
especially over the past
few days
it looks like another round of war is
in the making so it is very complicated
which it should deserve as much
attention from both internal and
external actors but internal actors are
more important i think
so do you do you believe that this is a
conflict that can be solved internally
or are you also pessimistic that there
will be another round of war coming uh
before i want to answer this question i
think i want to return back to the
points stated by
the panelists
i think i agree with the dynamics of the
political dynamics of uh the current
affairs of europe with those panelists
this is extremely
uh
complex uh i can agree with that
the other thing is that the treasure is
i disagree with the
uh statement made by puzzle that
the pressure is in
in the ethiopian
government
the reason why some
measures by our countries some pressure
is
in european government because
they are implementing a draconian
tactic
there is no moral in ground that this
government shouldn't have to be uh
leveled as such
and should be preserved even
to our context the project is not enough
because
i'm afraid i'm gonna have to jump in
there because we have come to the end of
the program uh do appreciate your time
all of you very much thank you for
joining us sued hassan william davidson
and bizuna getachu yemenu
and thank you too for watching you can
see the program again any time by
visiting our website that's
aljazeera.com and for further discussion
do you go to our facebook page that's
facebook.com aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
laura kyle and the whole team here it's
bye for now
[Music]